you mentioned this phrase islam is a
is a religion of peace yeah and whenever
there's a terrorist attack
by islamists and jihadis in this country
or anywhere else in europe
that seems to always be the line islam
is a religion of peace
you can't talk about it even open-minded
people like us who want to understand
what where different people are coming
from and they're not blaming
whole groups of people for certain
things
you can't say that particularly as a
white person you can't say that but even
as you said yourself as someone who's
from iran
from was brought up as a muslim you know
saying islam is not a religion of peace
which i imagine you believe
it's impossible so can you just talk to
us about why you don't think
islam is a religion i mean i don't think
any religion is a religion of peace i
mean religion
is based on you know murdering anyone
who is a
heretic an apostate you know you've got
the spanish inquisitions
we've got historical examples we've got
present-day examples
and the islamic movement has power in
many countries they're actually
crucifying people in the street
hanging people off of cranes for
apostasy for blasphemy for being gay
they're stoning
people to death in the streets so you
know it's not a hypothetical
discussion to say that islam or any
religion is not peaceful i think
religion actually
is you know the antithesis of peace
and justice and in fact you know it's
funny because they always talk about
religious morality
but really it's immorality from an
ethical point of view you know
so many of you know just to give you an
example in islam
it's immoral to have sex outside of
marriage so you have sex with someone
you love
but it's perfectly fine to have child
marriage which is pedophilia and child
rape
you know it's it's uh it's not possible
to hold hands with your partner someone
you love on the street because that's
considered
sexual mixing but it's perfectly fine to
specify the size of stone to stone
someone to death
for having an adulterous relationship or
for um
being a homosexual it's perfectly fine
to throw someone off a building because
they're gay
but you know it's haram to eat during
ramadan
i mean it's just the the unethical
nature of all religious precepts i think
it's clear i mean i i
i think the problem is because religion
is treated with such kid gloves
and there's so much respect for
something that is so not worthy of any
respect you know
and so i i know you don't look very
happy sorry no no no no
no no no no that [ __ ] that's my face
because i get that a lot when i'm
speaking people
my auntie's probably agrees with you
even more than i ever okay so yeah so i
think yeah so saying islam is a religion
of peace it's just
you know it's nonsense it's not true by
any measure
you just have to you know yeah they'll
say and and let me say this
my dad who's a muslim is the loveliest
kindest person in the world he wouldn't
hurt a fly
so again i'm not saying that muslims are
like that
or christians are like what the bible
says or jews are like what the torah
says you know in in the torah for
example
men pray thanking god that they weren't
born women you know
there's so many examples of that in all
religions so
because i think people are better than
their religions because people change
according and adapt according to
the age that they live in and books
really remain the same
and that's why interpretation is such a
big thing because people do interpret
things the way they want
but i think islam is not at all peaceful
and i understand why people say it
because they don't want muslims to be
targeted and rightfully so
you know now in sri lanka after the
attack on the church
muslims are being dragged out of their
homes their shops are being burnt down
they haven't done
anything you know and we've got lots of
ex-muslims who've had to flee the city
because of course they're also
considered muslims
and they've lost their homes they're
homeless so again
you can understand why people say that
but i think that's going about it the
wrong way
because you know everybody knows that's
not true and you're just
helping to not discuss the truth and
you're
sort of making muslims a target by not
saying the truth about things you know
and
i think that's where we need to be very
clear target believes target religious
right movements
never ever is targeting people
permissible in any circumstance
you